me making you feel attacked will always
hurt me so there's never a value in
being in you making me
afraid
there's never a long-term value in it
that's um
it's another thing that tall Roz when we
were writing a book
brace me on
because he said there's scientific data
out there that's called strategic
umbrage
well there's data well whether or not
it's scientific I would call that into
question
but he said there are studies out there
that show that strategic umbrage works
and
another thing that I also enjoy
uh you probably get tired of me saying
wonderful things about Andrew
there's never there's never enough
wonderful things to say about the great
Andrew huberman the host of the human
Lab podcast everybody should subscribe
to you should talk to Andrew you're
funnier than he is though I'll give you
that Andrew he's funny accidentally he
makes me laugh all the time not when
he's trying to be funny yeah he's a
really uh he's one of the people in this
world that's truly legit he's a really
strong scientist and a really strong
communicator and a good human being and
it those those together don't come often
and it's nice to see yeah yeah
yeah he's a treasure National Treasure
anyway you were saying well he he sort
of taught me how to think about that in
studies and Science and
and also from different uh books that
he's turned me on to it's really helped
me think about this stuff so the study's
about strategic umbrage
were done the ones that I've seen that
show it's effective
there were simulated negotiations with
college students
now here's the problem with that
a simulated negotiation with a college
student college students are going to
sit down as part of their assignment
they're going to sit down one time
they're going to sit down for 45 minutes
and they're going to think that if they
didn't come to a deal at all that they
failed and there's no ongoing
implementation there's just a deal and
then they walk away of a pretense
situation
so they got no actual real skin in the
game
There's No Deal on Earth do you sit down
and come to agreement 45 minutes and
never see each other again because
there's the implementation of the deal
if even if it's only payment
so the data is flawed based on the way
it was collected it's a highly flawed
study
and all that is flawed as you know as a
scientist you just got to be aware what
the flaws are and decide whether or not
that destroys the study or or what do
you think you take a look at the data
there's no such thing as perfect data
look at the data see what you think of
it the data that says the Strategic
umbrage works is based on flawed
circumstances can you explain strategic
umbrage get mad scaring the other side
into a deal
getting mad at using anger strategically
to bully the other side into an
agreement
that's nice to hear in some sense
it's nice to hear that empathy is the
right way in almost all situations
tonight best chance of success
not that it works every time just it
works more than anything else does